[Música]
hola bienvenidos a la revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio y las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo la
desinformación en internet se crea y se
expande a niveles incalculables pero
cada vez son más los espacios dedicados
a hacer frente a este fenómeno en esta
oportunidad les presentamos portal check
punto org una iniciativa que recopila
una serie de herramientas para verificar
datos y combatir la desinformación
frente al cob el 19 en américa latina'
empezamos
hace unos días la unesco junto al
verificador de contenidos argentinos
chequeado y el proyecto latinoamericano
latam chequea lanzaron portal check
punto org una iniciativa financiada por
la unión europea y cuyo objetivo es
desmentir la información falsa sobre el
cob y 19 en américa latina pero también
ayudarle a las personas a identificar
esos contenidos que se propagan en
internet sin ningún fundamento el sitio
cuenta con distintos apartados en los
que brindan herramientas y consejos a
usuarios creadores de contenido
periodistas y hasta académicos entre los
que hay recursos como vídeos podcasts
artículos noticiosos y libros y
precisamente para hablar de este tema
nos acompaña desde buenos aires laura
sommer ella es directora ejecutiva y
periodística de chequeado laura
bienvenida a france 24 y cuéntenos por
qué la necesidad de enfocar portal
sector en américa latina y el caribe y
por qué crear un portal de verificación
de hechos dedicado exclusivamente a
combatir la desinformación contra el
kobe 19
hay muchas razones que justifican porque
un portal contra la desinformación ahora
y en español una de ellas es que mucha
de la evidencia científica vinculada con
la pandemia no está siquiera traducida
al español en muchos papers muchas
investigaciones científicas están en
niños inglés y a veces las malas
traducciones
pueden generar desinformación y en este
contexto a veces miedo ansiedades o
malos cuidados en la gente
porque un portal contra la
desinformación ahora porque la
desinformación con la pandemia se
exacerbó
y en qué sentido se exacerbó encontramos
más que antes pero además
encontramos mucha gente con necesidad de
sacarse la incertidumbre esta nueva
enfermedad le trajo al mundo
y se agarra así de cualquier cosa que le
pueda a veces significar volver a la
antigua normalidad o salir de las
cuarentenas en los países que tienen
cuarentena o volver a la vida anterior
que mucha gente anhela la obra es
curioso que hay un apartado dedicado a
influenciadores donde se les ofrecen
tips para administrar el contenido que
promueven en sus redes porque aparecen
muchas veces desinformación en creadores
de contenidos con muchísimos seguidores
a veces con intención y otras tantas por
ignorancia que difunden desinformación
que puede ser muy dañina ellos son
actores relevantes hoy en el debate
público en el debate público global lo
que decidimos hacer importante que es
transparentar eso transparentar el rol
que hoy tienen los influenciadores
y generar contenido y convocarlos a que
en vez de ser
en parte del problema empiecen a ser
parte de la solución contribuyan a que
sus audiencias sean audiencias más
críticas más apegadas a los hechos a los
datos de la evidencia y que ellos tengan
una comunicación más responsable la hora
definitivamente es un tema que tiene
mucha tela por cortar seguramente más
adelante tendremos más tiempo vamos a
despedirnos pero antes de leh a nuestros
televidentes por favor un par de tips
para que actúen con más responsabilidad
bueno el primer consejo es que todos
estemos atentos que todos sepamos así
como decíamos sobre los influencias o
creadores de contenido que todos podemos
ser parte del problema de la
desinformación o parte de la solución
acostumbrémonos a tener una agenda
informativa que nos cuide que quiere
decir esto elijamos
a qué medios oa qué
actores públicos oa qué organismos vamos
a confiar les más porque tienen una
trayectoria de entregarnos buena
información y no de mentirnos sólo para
ganar clics y hacer dinero y la tercera
es utilizan recursos como por blanchett
generado en este caso por unesco en
alianza con chequeado y la tan chequea
para aprender más sobre este fenómeno la
desinformación llegó para quedarse
aunque no nos guste no es un fenómeno
que va a terminar y en parte depende de
nosotros estar más preparados para no
quedar entrar en la trampa
tenemos que terminar con el comparto por
las dudas cuidarnos hoy es por las dudas
no compartan
y hablando de noticias finalizamos en
australia en facebook los portales
informativos hoy se ven así aún no hay
publicaciones reza un anuncio en el feed
de cada una de estas páginas como si no
se hubiera publicado nunca nada por
disposición de facebook quienes viven en
australia no podrán ver ni compartir en
la plataforma contenidos de noticias de
medios de comunicación nacionales o
internacionales mientras quienes vivimos
fuera de australia no podemos ver ni
compartir noticias de sitios web
australianos en facebook la compañía
tomó esa decisión como respuesta a un
proyecto de ley del gobierno australiano
que requiere que las plataformas
digitales lleguen a un acuerdo con los
medios de comunicación para remunerarlos
por el contenido que generan y que se
mueven en estas redes la medida de
facebook fue fuertemente condenada por
líderes mundiales y empresas mediáticas
alrededor del mundo
hasta aquí revista digital recuerden que
si quiere repetir esta u otra misión de
nuestro programa lo pueden hacer a
través de nuestra página web www puntos
francia 4 puntocom
[Música]